exactly what if what if a woman comes to
you this for everybody what a woman
comes to you and says that and you tell
her you're delusional and she's like
well I don't want to lower my standards
to be able to get some random guy I'm
going to keep my standards like this
what would you guys say to her um I I'm
very much I say I was I don't really uh
call out you know the the rough part so
I just kind of I don't be around the
bush I'm just direct to it I just tell
her straight up like if you're expecting
this then you're not gonna get far with
what you want and you need to re-evalue
it and reassess
everything if you think
to this extreme and also like share the
example I gave earlier like the shingle
mother
obviously I'm not going to be like too
harsh because she's got at the end of
the day she got a kid to look after but